[Musique]
mais d'un bonjour merci d'être là pour
cette nouvelle émission dans des
lectures dont vous êtes là avec une
mission bien précise nous donner envie
de lire vos livres on va commencer par
vous présenter
donc je commence par vous à ma droite
alors madame piedoux un mois je suis
laetitia je suis assistante de
conservation à la médiathèque 17 mar je
m'occupe notamment d'acheter tout ce qui
est mon cas
comics livres de science fiction
voilà je laisse ou pas fins et jeunesse
et adultes et adultes c'est très bien et
vous alors j'ai rêvé que je suis raphaël
martins je travaille à la direction des
cultures de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
suis coordinatrice de l'action
culturelle d'accord très bien à vous moi
je suis et manon lacroix la grandeur et
je travaille à la médiathèque du canal à
montigny-le-bretonneux et je vais
également dans l'équipe qui organise
l'action culturelle pour la jeunesse les
enfants entre 3 et 10 ans et notamment
partir en livre cet été dont on vous
parlera tout à l'heure
très bien mais moi je suis annie je
travaille à la médiathèque jean
rousselot et je coordonne également
l'action culturelle pour les publics
adultes dans le réseau des médiathèques
et elle allait ou cette médiathèque jean
oslo elle est à gryon très bien donc
vous nous avez tout et 4 apporter un
livre un coup de coeur j'imagine
j'espère et bien vous allez nous en
parler écoutez on comment on continue
dans le même sens alors laetitia
joueuses écoute
qu'est ce que vous nous proposez de bol
à un jeu vous propose en comics alors
qu'est ce que tu as un comics a rempli
ses hommes sont l'équivalent de nos bd
franco-belge mai aux états unis en fait
c'est une bande dessinée américaine
ouais en gros mais celle ci c'est pas du
super héros c'est plus une petite fille
qu'ils s'appellent gertrude dont je me
présentais ayed ferryland de scotty
young donc a été dit et sur bande comics
donc c'est une petite fille tout type il
y en a qui aiment les choses lionne qui
vit dans une chambre rose et tout ça est
un jour la moquette de sa chambre laval
c'est vraiment une moquette vraiment
tout pour le tout et ça m'inquiète laval
et l'a fait littéralement tombé à
ferryland donc avec wiland c'est un
endroit très millions les étoiles parle
de soleil parle on y rencontre la reine
claude ya une très belle dame qui
s'habille en robe de nuages et tout ça
et tu lui dis ben écoute tu peux
repartir n'y a pas de souci mais tu vas
pouvoir vivre une aventure tu récupères
une clé et quand tu as récupère la clé
que tu as ouvert la porte tu prends à
rentrer chez toi à gertrude se dit que
ça va être assez facile sauf que j'ai un
truc ça fait 27 ans qu'elle cherche sa
clé avec 27 ans ferryland ça donne la
rend complètement dingue
elle est passée d'une petite fille qui
n'a en plus pas grandie physiquement à
une jeune femme complètement psychopathe
qui est tombé dans la violence la plus
totale
elle n'hésite pas à tuer en se servant
des anglais plus ou moins possible parce
que son but c'est vraiment de partir de
ça c'est un vrai coup de coeur a ses
raisons notamment parce qu'un ferry
landes
on ne peut pas dire de gros mots donc
pour la traduction le traducteur s'est
éclaté à dévier tout ce qu'on peut dire
de grossièretés au fait
gertrude est juste pas possible il ya
beaucoup de références au cinéma
la culture pop et tout ça mais c'est une
petite fille complètement ingérable et
de fait à la implorons du ferry landes
complètement ingérable un peu
psychopathe aussi ok très bien et alors
ce livre vous ayez destiné à quelque
soit complice mois du groupe madj sexy
qu'un blanc c'est violent il parle c'est
qu'il parle drogue c'est d'accord tous
les 6/7 - contes détournés en fait cette
démarche
et puis ça ça vire à vire complètement
ceux qui ont vu ce parc ou happy tree
friends rendre complètement dedans très
bien m'écouter merci laetitia alors
raphaël dites moi quel est votre choix
c'est complètement différent du mien est
le même ça penrose
voilà c'est une bd autobiographique de
michel kichka oui s'appelle deuxième
génération ce que je n'ai pas dire mon
père vous est donc c'est l'histoire de
sa famille en fait et c'est à travers
les non-dits de sa famille qui aimante
mais qui est très taiseuse et tout ça il
se rend compte que son père est un
rescapé de la shoah ne savaient pas ils
le savaient pas ils savaient pas ce que
ça ce que ça représentait en fait et au
fur et à mesure du livre on voit on voit
son cheminement à lui le cheminement de
sa famille et toute la toutes les
difficultés que ça peut poser à cette
deuxième génération qui n'a pas connu la
shoah mais qui a qu'il apporte dans son
dense dans ses racines ans et adosser
les répercussions et finalement de tous
ces non dits
et tout à fait donc c'est très touchant
c'est à la fois très intime et très
pudique et c'est une manière assez a
faim c'est un angle assez assez
intéressant pour aborder justement
l'histoire notre histoire et avec des
dessins très épuré c'est en noir et
blanc et c'est très très émouvant c'est
vraiment c'est un très très beau livre
que je conseille à tout le monde
chacune réseau des médiathèques
d'ailleurs joué elle a donc c'est un
album et vous le destinez à quel genre
de public a plutôt adulte plutôt adultes
adolescents et adultes jeunes adultes
oui oui tout à fait et ccc
remarquablement écrits et ses trésors
votre cas voilà très bien m'a écouté
massy alors nous vous écoutons alors que
manon dans un autre registre un album
jeunesse de john kodak ammoura qui
s'appelle saint camille donc en fait on
a reçu du mco nakamura l'illustratrice
dans nos médiathèque le mois dernier ok
c'est pardon c'est l'illustratrice tout
à fait enfin l'auteur illustratrice qui
valut des ateliers d'illustration avec
les enfants dans les médiathèques avons
que c'est aussi un petit clin d'oeil aux
rencontres vagabonde voilà qu'on
organisé en partenariat avec la
librairie la vagabonde de versailles
donc cinq amis se sont embrasés un
dromadaire un kangourou une chèvre et un
cochon qui vivent ensemble dans une
ferme et qui grandissent qu'ils sont
inséparables
mais un jour le temps passe et
les cinq amis vont vivre des aventures
aux quatre coins du monde
est-ce qu'on peut ouvrir le livre voirie
bien sûr sans bouger si c'est possible
donc évident la ferme d'accord et un
jour donc qui partent aux quatre coins
du monde
voilà on va rester sur une image
contraire ils se séparent et à partir de
ce moment là en fait si le bas ils sont
tous séparés au monde et malgré leur vie
exotiques et est idyllique
ils se demandent toujours chaque jour ce
que deviennent leurs vieux amis
ce manque voilà il se manque et on a
notamment une dernière image ou en fait
lors d'une nuit
de plus des toiles où il regarde tous la
même étoile filante et il faut tous le
même voeu de se retrouver ensemble un
jour
voilà c'est très belle histoire dallas
et c'est une belle histoire
les textes sont assez simples oui comme
les gommes dures et graves de tailleur
comme les graphismes
donc ça c'est pour quel genre de
dash d'enfants c'est pour les enfants
gérées à partir de 4 ans ce que ça
traite vraiment joliment le thème de
l'éloignement
on veut aller toucher voilà une limite
et vous avez tous chez les tout petits
enfants qui vont penser à leurs amis
d'école s'ils déménagent ou même à leurs
familles quand ils vont à la maternelle
mais ça peut toucher également les
adultes qui vont lire ces histoires aux
jeunes est en fait qui vont peut-être
déjà vécu cette histoire eux mêmes c'est
un album que je conseille à tout le
monde qui est très beau presque poétique
travers laquelle on lui dira très épuré
candidat final à annie alors qu'est ce
que vous nous proposez de boer alors moi
je vous propose quelque chose d'un peu
différent de tout ce qu'on a vu c'est
une lecture aux longues courbes ce que
c'est un pavé un vrai pavé qui fait plus
de 600 pages web a retiré c'est de la
littérature étrangère puisque c'est
traduit du danois auront et c'est un
livre d'un auteur qui s'appelle kim line
et le titre c'est là bim il a été publié
chez gallimard c'est son deuxième roman
traduit en français publié chez
gallimard
là c'est une véritable épopée qui va
nous faire suivre un couple de jumeaux
donc de deux garçons i b puis le
deuxième ne sait plus trop à l'écart des
prairies naturelles et ils ont les voies
entre
la fin de la première guerre mondiale en
mars 1918 jusqu'à la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale en réalité au tout début
du roman ses deux frères se sont engagés
volontairement aux côtés de l'armée
finlandaise yle hockey la jda pardon ils
sont tous jeunes ils ont 17 ans dans ces
eaux là car le prénom est ici il
s'engage auprès de l'armée finlandaise
en étant danois en étant danois pour
combattre pour combattre
les communistes qui ont envahi une
partie de la de la famille et donc ils
vont être complètement marquer
évidemment parce qu'ils vont vivre à ce
moment là et notamment la violence et le
le rapport à la mort et le rapport à la
violence
et est ce que peut procurer le fait de
donner la mort et le fait d'être violent
donc on va les suivre toute leur vie 1
dans au danemark ils vont vivre
différemment l'un de l'autre
il y en a qui va être plus
plus porté sur la psychiatrie qui va
devenir psychiatre médecin puis
psychiatre à quai et hypnotiseur à la
fin et l'autre qui va être plus
journaliste écrivain auteur voilà on
pourrait dire que ces deux jumeaux sont
en fait incarnent une double
personnalité ou une seule personnalité
qui a deux apps deux aspects pardon le
bien et le mal mais en fait c'est pas du
pourquoi il ya un gentil et un méchant
un peu mais c'est pas aussi simple que
ça non plus sur sur plusieurs décennies
évidemment tous les tous les aspects des
personnalités peuvent se réaliser mais
c'est c'est un vrai souffle
c'est un roman qui nous a parce que
franchement c'est très très dense 1 cm
seulement 600 pages mais c'est une toute
petite polices de caractères donc et
vous ça vous a pris complètement vous
l'avez comme ça d'un trait s'est
excellemment traduit c'est ça on sent
vraiment que la traduction est
impeccable ce qu'il faut savoir aussi
c'est que l'auteur et d une personnalité
un peu particulière qui a été élevé en
partie en norvège et donc il est aussi à
l'aise hors norvégien camp danois
même si dans ces deux pratiques
linguistiques il
il y met des choses différentes qui sont
inhérentes à la culture finlandaise très
bien mais voilà vous êtes captivé donc
c'est que c'est captivant c'est génial
ça donne envie et une fille ça fait un
bon moment pour l'été dans lequel se
plonger tout à fait peu rafraîchi sa
terreur du nord en plus
dites moi alors en ce moment quels sont
les projets les l'actualité culturelle
de saint quentin en yvelines vous avez
des choses à nous annoncer peut-être oui
dites moi je peux je peux tout vous dire
donc cet été on à partir en livre donc
c'est un événement national qui organisé
par le centre national du livre et qu'on
l'a été par le ministère de la culture
ça consiste en quoi alors alors en fait
c'est faire sortir le livre de ces lieux
habituels et
promouvoir le livre jeunesse aurait près
tout donc concrètement nous dans le
réseau des médiathèques
on a des événements extérieurs doit
avoir des terrasses des points lecture
des électeurs éventuel alors exactement
ont provoqué tout à fait et on aura deux
événements phares le lancement donc le
11 juillet à la médiathèque du canal
salles dès le départ de ne pas
réellement l'événement le début je veux
dire c'est ça donc avec une exposition
des éditions pastel qui fêtent leurs 30
ans cette année ok et un spectacle je
n'en dis pas plus nombreux et on aura la
soirée de clôture le 21 juillet et là
sera la commanderie des templiers
ok donc c'est tout le mois de juillet
tout avec les événements de ces deux
dates c'est ça allait payer donc d'être
sur le site des médiateurs restera tout
très prochainement génial m'écouter un
gros merci c'était très très différents
tous ces livres dont que ces riches ça
donne envie et à très bientôt pour de
nouvelles lectures remercie le diable
[Musique]